Let me go next to Jade from London.
Is this London, England?
London, Ontario.
London, Connecticut.
London, England.
So, London, England.
All right, Jade, welcome.
Hi.
I didn't actually think this would happen.
This is my first good ever.
Wow.
Well, I'm glad it is me.
Yeah, me too.
So I I'm a bit fascinated at the moment with
America.
I've never been you.
Hold on.
Let me clarify, Jade.
You've never been to America or you've never
before been fascinated with it.
Probably both.
Both, OK.
All right.
Very good.
But the election essentially tend to be nocturnal
because I was hooked and that's actually how
I found your channel.
And so I I've got a theory to run past you.
And I think you may be the only one to kind
of answer that question, please, just because
it may come off as a bit of a conspiracy theory.
But we know that Trump is in hundreds of millions
of dollars in debt.
Right.
We also know there's reports coming out is
selling loads of arms to dangerous people
all over.
All over the shop.
Yes.
Is it my, my, my my theory is that he is selling
all of these things, making backdoor deals
and all of these kind of things.
And I think he was banking on the fact that
he still had four more years as president
and as president because he may have some
sort of payment plan or something like this
to pay back all of his debts and where he
doesn't have that anymore.
A lot of these things are falling through.
And I think that's probably why he's panicking
and doing what he's doing and dragging out
the inevitable.
Well, that's kind of my theory.
It's not it's not a crazy theory in this sense,
Gayed, which is I do think that Trump believes
that the four hundred or so million that were
in debt that will come due over the next four
years, he would be in a stronger position
to either renegotiate or somehow get parts
of it written off or something if he were
the sitting president rather than a former
president.
I think that's undeniably true.
Now, the specifics about whether the arms
deals are related to it or these, I don't
know about that.
That's definitely more speculative.
But I think you're absolutely correct that
Trump would rather have four hundred million
in debt come to while being president than
the not that's it's a position of power.
There's no doubt about that.
Mm hmm.
Yeah, no, because people are talking to me
say these things.
My theory also slightly stems from the fact
that The Simpsons have predicted everything
and Trump dying.
So I genuinely think that all of this may
push him to the edge.
That's more of something happen him.
But listen, aside aside from The Simpsons,
Trump is an overweight mid 70s guy who hasn't
exercised ever.
So, I mean, it's not crazy to think that Donald
Trump's health may be in question.
I mean, not to get morbid, but it's not a
crazy thing to be thinking about.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, maybe that's maybe that's a little wishful
thinking, considering that we have our own
mini trump over here.
Yeah, of course.
This guy, whichever I don't know about you,
I would never wish death or illness upon anybody.
I just want them to go away politically.
You might wish death on some OK, huh?
I see hesitatingly.
OK, our connection has just gotten very poor,
so I really appreciate the call, hope to hear
from you again.
There is there's Jade from London whose call
I very much appreciate that is going to do
it for calls today.
I'm sorry, I was not able to get to more,
but we will take calls again.
We're going to take a quick break on the podcast,
TV show and radio show and be back with much
more right after this.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.